This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Welcome to the Make It So Index of Interaction Design. Friends, our producer Sam Greenspan has seen the color of the future. I have seen it. You have seen it. We all know that the color of the future is blue. Lesson 1, future screens are mostly blue. When science fiction becomes science fact, the team colors have already been chosen. Pretty much science fiction is blue.
这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。欢迎来到“就这么办：交互设计指数”。朋友们，我们的制作人萨姆·格林斯潘已经看到了未来的颜色。我看到了。你们也看到了。我们都知道，未来的颜色是蓝色。第一课，未来的屏幕大部分是蓝色的。当科幻小说变成科学事实时，团队的颜色就已经选好了。几乎所有的科幻小说都是蓝色的。
1968, Denon Blue, 1976, Egyptian Blue, 1979, Ultramarine, 1988, Potter Blue. Blue it is inhuman, future looking kind of mystical. That's Chris Nassel, sci-fi aficionado. There's not a lot of blue in nature, right? There's not a lot of blue in nature, right? There's not a lot of blue food. So I think there is something fundamentally inhuman about that color or unnatural. Yeah, and that really fits the technologies of the future world As contrast. Yeah, the other guy is Nathan Shedrov also in design and like many sci-fi guys They're love of the art form takes on an obsessive quality.
1968年，丹东蓝；1976年，埃及蓝；1979年，群青；1988年，波特蓝。蓝色给人一种非人感、未来感和某种神秘感。那是克里斯·纳塞尔，一位科幻迷。自然界中其实没有太多蓝色，对吧？自然界中其实没有太多蓝色，对吧？自然界中没有太多蓝色的食物。所以我觉得这种颜色在本质上有一种非人感或不自然感。是的，这与未来世界的科技作为对比非常契合。是的，另一位是内森·谢德罗夫，他也是从事设计的，和许多科幻迷一样，他们对这种艺术形式的热爱达到了一种痴迷的程度。
And here's the thing, Chris and Nathan are also designers. Chris is with a firm called Cooper, and Nathan is on faculty at the California College of the Arts, both in San Francisco. Sci-fi obsession met design obsession and the resulting glorious nerd fest was a book. Where are the authors of the book make it so? Interaction Design Lessons from Science Fiction.
事情是这样的，克里斯和内森也是设计师。克里斯在一家名为库珀的公司工作，内森是旧金山加利福尼亚艺术学院的教员，两人都在旧金山。科幻迷的痴迷与设计界的痴迷碰撞在一起，由此诞生了一场光荣的极客狂欢——一本书。他们就是新书《就这么办：科幻小说中的交互设计教训》的作者。
Make It So is a comprehensive compendium of real-world lessons that designers can and should and do take from science fiction. So to give you an idea of how exhausted their line of inquiry is, that lesson about future screens being mostly blue. Lesson one, future screens are mostly blue. Nathan and Chris actually figured this out empirically. They built a database of more than 10,000 images from sci-fi movies. 1982, Royal Blue, 1983, Prussian Blue, 1986, 90, 1990, Perry Wimbledon.
《就这么办》是一部全面的纲要，总结了设计师可以、应该并且确实从科幻小说中汲取的现实世界的经验。为了让你对他们研究方向的深入程度有一个概念，关于未来屏幕大部分是蓝色的那一课。第一课，未来屏幕大部分是蓝色的。内森和克里斯实际上是通过经验主义的方法得出这一结论的。他们建立了一个数据库，里面收录了来自科幻电影的10000多张图片。1982年，皇家蓝；1983年，普鲁士蓝；1986、90、1990年，长春花蓝。
Then I went through and I sort of cropped out the key screens of interfaces. Stuck them into Photoshop for a given year, shrunk them down to a single pixel, and then pumped the saturation. 1996, Iris Blue, 1997, Aquamarine, 1999, shrunk them down to a single pixel, and then pumped the saturation. 1996, Iris Blue, 1997, Aquamirine, 1999, Baby Blue, 2000, Miniblu, 2002, Aquamirine, again. And from that, they could determine the average color of all interfaces from every sci-fi movie that came out in a given year.
然后我浏览并裁剪了界面上的关键屏幕。把它们放进特定年份的Photoshop里，缩小到一个像素，然后拉高饱和度。1996年，鸢尾蓝；1997年，海蓝宝；1999年，缩小到一个像素，然后拉高饱和度。1996年，鸢尾蓝；1997年，海蓝宝；1999年，婴儿蓝；2000年，迷彩蓝；2002年，又是海蓝宝。由此，他们可以确定某个特定年份上映的所有科幻电影中所有界面的平均颜色。
And when you lay those average colors next to each other, you can see. 1968 to 2011, pretty much science fiction is blue. There are some exceptions. 1973, Umbra Brown 1977, Ken Jareem 1991, for 1991, Scarlet Red, the very red Terminator 2. But for the most part, if you just blur your eyes and glance at it, you can see that it's always blue. 2003, Darks Arulian, 2004, Slightly Darker Baby Blue, 2005, Nant Green, 2008, again with the Aquamarine, Slightly Darker this time, 2009, Big Cluster that Baby Blue from 2004, 2010, Navy Blue. Of course, the point of the world.
当你把这些平均颜色并排放在一起时，你就能看出来。从1968年到2011年，几乎所有的科幻小说都是蓝色的。也有一些例外。1973年，暗影褐；1977年，肯·贾里姆；1991年，呃，1991年，猩红，非常红的《终结者2》。但大多数情况下，如果你眯起眼睛大致扫一眼，你会发现它总是蓝色的。2003年，深天青石蓝；2004年，稍微深一点的婴儿蓝；2005年，南特绿；2008年，又是海蓝宝，这次稍微深一点；2009年，大批2004年那样的婴儿蓝；2010年，海军蓝。当然，这里的重点是……
Of course, the point here is not to forecast what technology will actually look like. Screens of the future may or may not actually be blue. But sci-fi is about letting our imaginations run wild and create imagined worlds, and someone has to design the experience of characters moving through that imagined world, and even if your sci-fi world is at thousand years in the future, those choices are in constant dialogue with the present. When Chris and Nathan started this project, they went back to the very first sci-fi film,
当然，这里的重点并不是预测技术实际上会是什么样子。未来的屏幕实际上可能是蓝色的，也可能不是。但科幻小说的意义在于让我们的想象力尽情驰骋，创造出想象中的世界，而且总得有人去设计角色穿梭于这个想象世界中的体验，即使你的科幻世界是在一千年后的未来，这些选择也与现在保持着持续的对话。当克里斯和内森开始这个项目时，他们回溯到了最早的科幻电影，
Le Voyage de la Lune, a trip to the moon by Georges Mellier. It was actually one of the first films, period. It premiered in 1902. And the thing that I noticed when I saw that movie was, wait a minute, where the hell of the interface is, because there aren't any. In this future, as seen from 1902, you send people to the moon by putting them inside a giant canister,
乔治·梅里爱的《月球旅行记》。它实际上是最早的电影之一。它于1902年首映。当我看到那部电影时，我注意到的事情是，等一下，界面到底在哪个鬼地方，因为根本没有。在这个从1902年的视角来看的未来里，你把人们送上月球的方法是把他们塞进一个巨大的罐子里，
loading that canister into an enormous cannon, you light a wick, and then bang! That's how you get to the moon. The audience and even the filmmakers still had an industrial age paradigm. In their lives, they only ever encountered levers and buttons maybe. Technology and electricity were kind of a strange and off-putting thing. The 1902 audience did not require any type of UI for a lunar spacecraft, which tells you something about living in 1902. But Chris and Nathan say sci-fi doesn't just reflect reality, reality sometimes reflects sci-fi.
把这个罐子装进一门巨大的大农炮里，点燃导火索，然后——砰！这就是你到达月球的方式。观众甚至电影制作人仍然持有工业时代的范式。在他们的生活中，他们可能只遇到过杠杆和按钮。技术和电力在当时是一种奇怪且让人退避三舍的东西。1902年的观众不需要为月球飞船配备任何类型的用户界面，这说明了1902年的生活状态。但克里斯和内森说，科幻小说不仅反映现实，现实有时也会反映科幻小说。
That when components of science fiction saturate the public imagination, it can affect how we design things. Case in point, one of Motorola's first cell phones, the microtack. And it was not a particularly successful phone. Now, the microtack was a flip phone that opened downward. You held the device in your hand, and the mouthpiece flipped down so you could talk into it. And the microtack wasn't selling. So the Motorola engineers in Illinois took it down the road to the Argon National Laboratory.
当科幻小说的元素渗透到公众的想象中时，它会影响我们设计事物的方式。典型的例子是摩托罗拉的第一款手机之一，MicroTAC。而且它并不是一款特别成功的手机。MicroTAC是一款向下打开的翻盖手机。你把设备拿在手里，话筒部分向下翻开，这样你就可以对着它说话。而且MicroTAC卖得并不好。于是伊利诺伊州的摩托罗拉工程师把它带到了附近的阿贡国家实验室。
And the Argon engineers immediately said, oh, you made it wrong. And the Motorola folks were like, what do you mean? No one's ever made one of these. How do you know it's wrong? You know, like on Star Trek. And they said it has to open up like this. The Argon engineers just expected the phone to open upwards, like Captain Kirk's communicator.
阿贡的工程师们立刻说：“哦，你们做错了。”摩托罗拉的人则问：“你们是什么意思？从来没有人做过这种东西。你们怎么知道它错了？”你知道的，就像《星际迷航》里那样。他们说它必须这样向上打开。阿贡的工程师们只是期望手机能像柯克船长的通信器那样向上打开。
Downwards just felt weird. And they went back and made it open the right way. And then the next generation, well, that phone went gangbusters. And it was called the StarTac. Motorola accidentally happened into a system where their customers had been trained for 30 years of reruns on the right way to do mobile communication. There's actually a whole host of design lessons to take from Star Trek.
向下打开感觉怪怪的。于是他们回去把它改成了正确打开方式。接下来的那代产品，嗯，那款手机大获成功。它被称为StarTAC。摩托罗拉无意中进入了一种系统，他们的客户已经通过30年的重播接受了关于移动通信正确方式的培训。实际上，可以从《星际迷航》中汲取大量的设计经验。
Lesson 2. Establish a comprehensive visual syntax. Star Trek, the next generation, excelled at creating a holistic visual syntax. And it was probably thanks to extreme budget constraints. They didn't have the production budget to just wire tons of surfaces with dummy buttons and have them lit individually so that they could control them. And as a cost-saving move, they sort of developed this idea of, well, we can just print out film and backlight it under surfaces and that can serve as the sort of developed this idea of, well, we can just print out film and backlight it under surfaces
第二课。建立一个全面的视觉语法。《星际迷航：下一代》在创造整体视觉语法方面表现出色。这可能要归因于极端的预算限制。他们没有那么多的制作预算在无数的表面上接线假按钮并单独点亮它们以便进行控制。作为一项节省成本的举措，他们开发了一种想法，即我们可以把胶片打印出来，并在表面下方进行背光照明，这可以作为一种……开发了一种想法，即我们可以把胶片打印出来，并在表面下方进行背光照明，
and that can serve as the sort of wow factor of, man, there's a lot of controls for this, it must be a starship. Working. Ready. If you've seen one episode, you know what this looks like. A flat screen with a black backdrop and a bunch of brightly colored buttons underneath a glass exterior. They're everywhere on the ship, the bridge, the sick bay, engineering, they're on the tablet computers. Essentially all of the controls show up that way. They all have this uniformity about them that not only looks cool, but also tells you from a very quick glance that it's related to Star Trek.
这可以起到一种惊艳的作用，让人觉得，天哪，这个东西有这么多的控制装置，它一定是一艘星际飞船。工作中。准备就绪。如果你看过一集，你就知道这看起来像什么。一个带有黑色背景的平板屏幕，在玻璃外观下方有一堆色彩鲜艳的按钮。它们在飞船上无处不在：舰桥、医务室、工程舱，它们在平板电脑上。基本上所有的控制装置都是这样显示的。它们都有着这种统一性，不仅看起来很酷，而且能让你一眼就看出它与《星际迷航》有关。
They even gave the interface a name, L-Cars. They even give the interface a name, L-Cars. Accessing library computer data. This computer terminal provides full access to the L-Cars computer net. It can be operated both by voice and key dead commands. I do have the definition for those curious. It stands for library computer access slash retrieval system. There you go. L-Cars was the archetype of the image under glass paradigm that governs our virtual lives.
他们甚至给这个界面起了一个名字，L-CARS。他们甚至给这个界面起了一个名字，L-CARS。正在访问图书馆计算机数据。这个计算机终端提供对L-CARS计算机网络的完全访问。它可以通过语音和键盘命令进行操作。对于好奇的人，我确实有它的定义。它代表图书馆计算机访问及检索系统。就是这样。L-CARS是统治我们虚拟生活的“玻璃下图像”范式的原型。
And people really latched on to it. To this day, there are still people modding their computers and tablet devices to make them look like an L-cars device from the 24th century by way of the late 1980s and early 90s. But here is a really brilliant thing about Star Trek. Every single species has their own equivalent of L-Cars. So the Klingon race, for instance, it's all red triangles. The Bajorans have the sort of bluish purple oval thing, and the Borg have an array of green circles and green lighting everywhere.
人们确实对它情有独钟.时至今日，仍然有人在改装他们的电脑和平板设备，让它们看起来像是20世纪80年代末90年代初风格的24世纪L-CARS设备。但《星际迷航》真正牛的地方在于：每一个物种都有他们自己版本的L-CARS。比如克林贡人，全都是红色的三角形。巴霍兰人有一种蓝紫色的椭圆形东西，而博格人则到处都是绿色的圆圈阵列和绿色的灯光。
It's a semiotic lesson for storytelling, right? Green equals Borg, and wherever green creeps, you know the Borg are. It's sort of essentially a visual macro for an entire class of stories. It's their own brand and the really good brand managers. Yeah, they have good brand managers. But Chris and Nathan are quick to point out that not everything we see in sci-fi is necessarily good or even feasible. From the minute we started our interview, they could not wait to go off on how much of a waste of time they think gestural interfaces are. Think minority report.
这是一个关于讲故事的符号学教训，对吧？绿色等于博格人，无论绿色蔓延到哪里，你就知道博格人就在那里。这基本上是整个一类故事的视觉宏。这是他们自己的品牌，而且是非常优秀的品牌经理。是的，他们有优秀的品牌经理。但克里斯和内森急忙指出，我们在科幻小说中看到的东西并非全都是好的，甚至并非都是可行的。从我们开始采访的第一分钟起，他们就迫不及待地开始抨击他们认为手势界面是多么浪费时间。想想《少数派报告》。
When you move your arms in space, that's called cardio. That's aerobic exercise and it's tiring. Lesson 3. Avoid gestural interfaces. Supposedly Tom Cruise had to keep taking breaks on the set because these things tired him out. That future of looked exhausting. Even if conducting your computer like an orchestra turns out to be a dead end, that bad interface of that
当你在太空中挥舞手臂时，这叫有氧运动。这是有氧锻炼，而且很累。第三课。避免手势界面。据说汤姆·克鲁斯在片场不得不不断休息，因为这些东西把他累坏了。那个未来的样子看起来让人精疲力竭。即使把你的电脑当成管弦乐队指挥结果证明是一条死路，那个想象中的未来的糟糕界面，
imagined future can help you think about actual user interfaces of the present. And that's how we can get into apologetics. Lesson four, employ apologetics wherever possible. Apologetics is a term borrowed from religion primarily. It's the practice of coming up with rational explanations to reconcile the apparent contradictions inside of a faith. Basically, making sense of the plot holes
也能帮助你思考当下的实际用户界面。这就是我们如何进入“辩护学”的领域。第四课。尽可能运用辩护学。“辩护学”这个词主要借用自宗教。它是指提出理性解释来调和信仰内部明显矛盾的做法。基本上，就是为当各种宗教故事叠加在一起时浮现出的
that surface when various religious stories are stacked on top of each other. This can become applicable to sci-fi. If you just assume for the sake of argument that everything in sci-fi is there for a reason, you can find some really interesting lessons in design. So let's consider Star Wars, namely that part when Luke and Han Solo are in the Millennium Falcon blowing up TIE fires. Haha! Haha! Haha! I got him!
剧情漏洞赋予合理性。这可以应用到科幻小说中。如果你为了论证起见，只是假设科幻小说中的每件事都有其存在的理由，你就能在设计中发现一些非常有趣的教训。那么让我们考虑一下《星球大战》，也就是卢克和韩·索罗在千年隼号上炸毁钛战机的那段。哈哈！哈哈！哈哈！我击中他了！
I got him! Bring him! Don't get cocky! Now, if we were really in space watching these ships blow up, we wouldn't hear anything. I mean, it only takes that moment where you have to describe it and you realize, wait a minute, they're fighting in the vacuum of space. Where exactly is the sound propagating? Because sound is how our brain interprets the vibration of air molecules.
我击中他了！干掉他！别太自负了！现在，如果我们真的在太空中看着这些飞船爆炸，我们是什么也听不到的。我的意思是，只有当你必须描述它时，你才会意识到，等一下，他们是在太空真空中战斗。声音到底是在哪里传播的？因为声音是我们的大脑对空气分子振动的解释。
Of which there aren't any in space. So why do we hear these ships exploding in the film? The easy answer would be, oh, that's just Lucas trying to make something that feels right to people who were used to World War II film footage. But in fact, if you imagine that scene without the audio, it's a lot more miserable of a task to know where in 3D space are these tie fighters around me. How would I find them? Sure, you could give me a screen, but that requires me that I take my eyes off of the action.
而太空中并没有空气分子。那么为什么我们在电影中听到这些飞船爆炸的声音呢？简单的回答会是，哦，那只是卢克试图让习惯了二战电影片段的人觉得真实。但事实上，如果你想象一下没有音频的那个场景，去弄清楚这些钛战机到底在我周围的三维空间的什么位置，将是一项痛苦得多的任务。我怎么找到它们呢？当然，你可以给我一个屏幕，但这需要我把视线从行动中移开。
You could give me a heads up display, which might work, but audio is 360 degrees, much more than my, what is it, 120 degrees of vision? So that if that audio wasn't there, then you would expect somebody to put sensors on the outside of the Millennium Falcon and provide 3D sound inside the gunnership that would put that audio there. So the sound is an interface? The sound is the main part of the interface there, right? Yes, Luke can look
你可以给我一个平视显示器，这可能会有用，但音频是360度的，远比我的——是多少来着？——120度视野要广得多。所以，如果那个音频不存在，那么你就会期望有人在千年隼号的外侧安装传感器，并在炮手舱内提供3D声音，从而把那个音频放在那里。所以声音是一个界面？声音是那里界面的主要部分，对吧？是的，卢克可以看到
at this tie fighter, but he's also aware that coming over his right shoulder is another one that as soon as he, this one explodes, he's got to turn his gun and take care of. That's vital to that interface of working. And you can only get there by trying to reconsieve why does that thing that seems broken would really work. Okay, so here's another one. 2001 a space odyssey directed by Stanley Kubrick. So in 2001 Dr. Floyd is on a satellite and making a video call to his daughter back on Earth. Yes! Hello!
这架钛战机，但他也意识到，从他的右肩膀上方正在逼近另一架，一旦这架爆炸了，他就得转动他的枪去对付那一架。这对于该界面的运作至关重要。你只有通过重新构想为什么那个看起来坏了的东西其实能行，才能得出这个结论。好吧，还有一个。由斯坦利·库布里克导演的《2001太空漫游》。所以在2001年，弗洛伊德博士在一个卫星上，正在给地球上的女儿进行视频通话。太棒了！你好！
Hi! Are you a Squirt? Uh! What are you doing? Hey! Where's mommy? Gone to something. And then you see his daughter start button mashing the controls on the video phone.
嗨！你是小不点吗？啊！你在干什么？嘿！妈妈在哪儿？去某某地方了。然后你看到他的女儿开始在视频电话的控制面板上疯狂按按钮。
But strangely you don't hear any of the buttons. Now you can think, hey that's wrong, what was the sound designer sleeping on the job, but with our apologetics had on. But in fact, that's the way it ought to work. If you had a system that was context aware, and that would include awareness of the identity of its user, it would say, hmm, I've looked at this conversation. No one has asked this little girl to push a button. She's a little girl of about five or six years old, and it's indiscriminate mashing.
但奇怪的是，你听不到任何按钮的声音。现在你可能会想，嘿，这不对啊，音效设计师是不是在工作时偷懒了？但如果我们戴上辩护学的眼镜。事实上，这才是它应有的运作方式。如果你有一个能够感知上下文的系统，并且它包括对用户身份的感知，它就会说：“嗯，我看了这段对话。没有人要求这个小女孩去按按钮。她是一个大约五六岁的小女孩，这只是胡乱按一通。
I can safely disregard this as input. It's not a crisis. It's not a selection of any sort. So if you were designing a system that was truly context aware, that's exactly the way you would build it. And anyone with a, who's had to have a telephone call with a kid would know this is actually the way it should be built. And so the inputs to the interface are just not getting relayed.
我可以安全地将其忽略作为输入。这既不是危机，也不是任何形式的选择。”所以，如果你正在设计一个真正能感知上下文的系统，这正是你构建它的方式。任何和小孩通过电话的人都会知道，这实际上就是它应该被构建的方式。因此，界面的输入只是没有被转发。
The interface is actively interpreting them. Lesson five interfaces should not just interpret, but also report. That's only broken if you presume that the interface is a dumb capturing device, like a television camera. If instead you're reconsitive of it as sort of a real-time scanner, interpreter, and presenter, you've got an opportunity there to actually interpret the information. Let's do one more.
界面正在积极地解释它们。第五课：界面不仅应该解释，还应该报告。只有当你假设界面是一个像电视摄像机那样愚蠢的捕获设备时，它才是坏的。相反，如果你把它重新构想为一种实时扫描仪、解释器和呈现者，你就在那里获得了一个真正解释信息的机会。我们再做一个。
This one's kind of tricky, but stick with it. Lesson six. Find the human factor in technological shortcomings. For this lesson, we go to a movie called Logan's Run, where there's this interface called the circuit, which people of this post-apocalyptic world used to find sex partners. It's Craigslist.
这个有点棘手，但请坚持下去。第六课：在技术缺陷中寻找人性因素。对于这一课，我们来看一部名为《逃离地下天堂》的电影，里面有一个叫做“电路”的界面，这个后末日世界的人们用它来寻找性伙伴。这就是Craigslist。
It's even weirder than Crucky. It is a lot weirder than Cruckyett. It is a lot weirder. And actually I just saying something So Logan is hanging out in his apartment of the future and he turns on this thing called the circuit Which basically lets him tune in different people who are ostensibly available for Coupling anyway the thing about the circuit is that it's a really clumsy piece of technology We can see that it takes kind of a long time to tune someone in, and then it's up to Logan to decide a quick yes or no as to whether he wants to pull that person into his apartment or send them back out into the ether.
它甚至比Cruckyett还要怪异。它确实比Cruckyett怪异得多。它怪异得多。其实我只是随口一说……所以洛根正闲晃在他的未来公寓里，他打开了这个叫做“电路”的东西，这基本上让他能够调谐到不同的人，这些人表面上都可以用来进行伴侣配对。不管怎样，“电路”的问题在于它是一个非常笨拙的技术。我们可以看到，调谐某个人需要相当长的时间，然后由洛根来决定一个快速的是或否，以决定他是否想把这个人拉进他的公寓，或者把他们送回虚空中。
As an interface, it's unbelievably bad. For lots of reasons. Like the male gaze problem alone in this case is just morally reprehensible. But if you can get past that for a second, just notice that the circuit only lets you tune in one person at a time. And you have to give a quick yes, no answer as to whether you want that person coming into your apartment. If he's going along and he sort of says, oh, number one's not good, number two's not good, number three's not good, number four's not okay,, maybe was it two or one that was better? Well, maybe I can go back But you don't see a mechanism to go back and to make things worse there seems to be no ability to adjust the settings of what or
作为一个界面，它好得难以置信地差。出于很多原因。比如仅在这个案例中的男性凝视问题就简直是道德沦丧。但如果你能把这搁置一秒钟，只要注意“电路”一次只允许你调谐一个人。而且你必须对是否希望这个人进入你的公寓给出一个快速的是或否的回答。如果他一路看下来，然后说，哦，第一个不好，第二个不好，第三个不好，第四个也不好，也许……是第二个还是第一个更好？好吧，也许我可以回去……但你看不到一个可以回去的机制，更糟糕的是，似乎无法调整……的设置。
Who you might want Like the first person that Logan tunes in is a guy and you can see right away that our hero It's not want to pull him or any other dude into his apartment. Pardon my gender or sexuality binary here, but one of the most fundamental things you would name is what's the gender of my possible partners, and he didn't have a single preference setting on this interface, so it just seems horrible. But there is evidence that this design has some merit if you can think of an apologetic for it. Listen.
或者你可能想要什么样的人。就像洛根调谐的第一个人是个男的，你可以马上看到我们的英雄并不想把他或其他任何男人拉进他的公寓。原谅我这里的性别或性取向二元论，但你可以命名的最基础的事情之一就是我的潜在伴侣的性别是什么，而他在这个界面上连一个偏好设置都没有，所以这看起来太糟糕了。但有证据表明，如果你能为它想出一个辩护理由，这个设计还是有一些可取之处的。听着。
I used to play this game with friends of mine called the 11th Man Game. The 11th Man Game or the 11th Woman Game depending on who you're playing it with, works as follows. When you're sitting in a public place, you pick a doorway and you challenge that friend and you say, OK, I want you to pick one of the next 10 people to walk through that doorway to date or if you had that sort of friendship have sex with and or you will be forced to do that same thing with the 11th person.
我过去常常和我的一些朋友玩一个游戏，叫做“第十一人游戏”。“第十一人游戏”或“第十一人女人游戏”（取决于和你一起玩的人是谁），其运作方式如下：当你坐在公共场所时，你选定一个门口，然后向那个朋友发起挑战，并说：“好吧，我希望你从接下来穿过那个门走出来的10个人里挑出一个来约会，或者如果你有那种友谊的话，和其发生性关系，否则你将被迫对第十一个人做同样的事情。”
Okay, so you're with me, you see person one, yes or no, you say no, you get person two, yes or no, say no, you get person three. You can't go back and pick a previous person. No going back. And if you say no all the way up through the 10th person, you have to take the 11th person. So according to Chris, when you start off playing the game.
好吧，所以你同意了，你看到了第一个人，是或否？你说否；你得到了第二个人，是或否？你说否；你得到了第三个人。你不能回去挑选以前的人。不能回头。如果你一直对前10个人说不，你就必须接受第11个人。所以根据克里斯的说法，当你开始玩这个游戏时。
You begin to play this, people are looking at negatives. Oh, let's pretend I'm playing with a heterosexual man. He'd be like, oh no, she's too short or I don't like her hair color or whatever. And eventually they would get to 11 and go, whoa, I didn't expect that I'd be with a grandma. And then he'd freak out or whatever. But after playing for a while, there's this shift in strategy from looking for reasons to reject someone,
你开始玩这个，人们都在寻找负面的东西。哦，假装我和一个异性恋男人一起玩。他会说，哦不，她太矮了，或者我不喜欢她的发色，诸如此类。然后他们最终会到达第11个，然后说，哇，我没料到我会和一个老奶奶在一起。然后他会抓狂或者别的什么。但在玩了一段时间后，策略发生了转变，从寻找拒绝某人的理由，
to looking for reasons to accept someone. Over time, the strategy shifts from that negative view to a very positive one, which what is not wrong with this person, but what is right with this person, and then being satisfied with that choice. And over time, people begin to adopt that positive search mode. So if the designer of the circuit's computer wants Logan to find a mate that he's going to be happy about, and the limits of the technology are such that Logan can only specify yes or no and can't go back to a previous choice.
转变为寻找接受某人的理由。随着时间的推移，策略从那种消极的看法转变为非常积极的看法，即这个人有什么地方没有错，而是这个人有什么地方是对的，然后对这个选择感到满意。随着时间的推移，人们开始采用这种积极的搜索模式。因此，如果“电路”计算机的设计者希望洛根找到一个他会感到高兴的伴侣，而技术的局限性在于洛根只能指定是或否，并且不能回到之前的选择。
Then, displaying a throwaway candidate early on will make Logan more likely to find an acceptable choice sooner because he's immediately primed to look for the positive attributes in the candidates that follow. Ta-da! It's super subtle and in fact, I think when I first started talking about this I kept talking about how bad it was and then stumbled across this goodness, which is a good way to get to apologetics, is any.
那么，在早期展示一个要抛弃的候选人，会让洛根更有可能更快地找到一个可以接受的选择，因为他立刻被引导去寻找后续候选人的积极属性。嗒哒！这超级微妙，事实上，我想当我第一次开始谈论这个时，我一直在谈论它有多糟糕，然后偶然发现了这个妙处，这是进入辩护学的一个好方法，那就是任何……
I love this game of design apologetics, because greater knowledge and awareness usually leads us down a path of miserable nitpicking. And I'm all for good criticism, but if you can apply a design solution to account for a bad design decision in a sci-fi movie, it uses the same decision in a sci-fi movie, it uses the same critical muscle, but in a different way, and the apologetics are endless. Like for example, let's take lesson number three about bad gestural interfaces. Maybe in the minority report world, people were really sedentary, and these types of interfaces were the way to get people to get some frickin' exercise. Strike lesson three.
我喜欢这种设计辩护学的游戏，因为更多的知识和意识通常会引导我们走上一条痛苦挑剔的道路。我完全支持好的批评，但如果你能运用一个设计方案来解释科幻电影中糟糕的设计决定，它就会在科幻电影中运用相同的决定，它运用了相同的批判肌肉，但方式不同，而且辩护是无止境的。比如，让我们以关于糟糕的手势界面的第三课为例。也许在《少数派报告》的世界里，人们真的很久坐不动，而这类界面就是让人类做一些该死的运动的方法。推翻第三课。
Gestural interfaces might be okay. And it leads us to our final lesson. the way to get people to get some frickin' exercise. And it leads us to our final lesson. Since talking sci-fi apologetics with Chris and Nathan, I can't help but look for them everywhere now. I even found one that had escaped them. We had gone off on some tangent about the Star Wars prequels. Queen Amidala has an interface for which we cannot apologize. Which is ironic because I believe I deserve an
手势界面可能还不错。这就引出了我们的最后一课：让人类做一些该死的运动的方法。这就引出了我们的最后一课。自从和克里斯和内森讨论了科幻辩护学之后，我现在忍不住到处寻找它们。我甚至找到了一个他们漏掉的。我们曾扯到关于《星球大战》前传的一些题外话。阿米达拉女王有一个我们无法为其辩护的界面。这很讽刺，因为我相信我应该为《星球大战》前传的每一个方面得到一个……
apology for every aspect of the Star Wars prequels. On her giant silvery spaceship, and I'm sure it has a name somewhere in the Star Wars canon, but I can't remember. I should get this sort of big panel of controls, but when you review it, the three times that she uses an interface aboard the ship, they are for routing a hologram or a volumetric projection across the galaxy. Second time she uses it is for summoning a star chart of a distant planet, I think it's Genocha. And the third is to land her spacecraft on Corsair. But when you look at those interfaces, the actually interaction she has is to press the exact same button on the panel,
道歉。在她巨大的银色飞船上，我确信它在《星球大战》正史中某个地方有个名字，但我记不清了。我得到了这样一个巨大的控制面板，但当你回顾时，她在这艘飞船上使用界面的三次机会，都是为了在全银河系路由全息图或立体投影。她第二次使用它时是为了召唤一颗遥远行星的星图，我想那是吉诺西斯。第三次是将她的飞船降落在科洛桑。但当你查看这些接口时，她实际上的交互是在面板上按下完全相同的按钮，
on the ship, to do all three things, and nothing else. So their gripe is that you see her using the same single button for very different tasks. Right, but I actually came up with my very own apologetic. You know, if she's the queen, she probably has a lot of underlings. And there's probably someone,
在飞船上，来做所有这三件事，除此之外什么都没有。所以他们的抱怨是，你看到她为非常不同的任务使用同一个单独的按钮。没错，但我实际上想出了我自己的辩护。你知道的，如果她是女王，她可能有很多下属。而且可能有人，
somewhere offscreen who does everything for her, and this is the make it so button. I like that. There's like a computer management, communications management room somewhere on the ship and they're just like, oh, she wants to do something. I like that. It'd be hilarious if she pressed the button
在屏幕外的某个地方为她做一切事情，这就是“就这么办”按钮。我喜欢这样。飞船上的某个地方有一个计算机管理、通信管理室，他们就像是，哦，她想做点什么。我喜欢这样。如果她按下按钮，另一个房间里就会响起铃铛，那就太搞笑了。字面上就是一根绳子系着一个小铃铛。那是她的晚餐。如果她按下按钮，另一个房间里就会响起铃铛，那就太搞笑了。字面上，是一根绳子系着一个小铃铛。这将是杰普斯按钮。没错。做我们刚刚含糊讨论过的那件事吧。《百分之九十九隐形》本周由萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播KALW以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。
and a bell rang in another room. Literally a little bell on a string. It's her dinner. It would be hilarious if she pressed the button and a bell rang in another room. Literally, a little bell on a string. It would be the jeeps button. Right. Do that thing we were discussing vaguely. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sam Greenspan, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7, Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook.
我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@SamListens，艾弗里是@Truffleman，但现在，科幻界面的优点、缺点和丑陋之处都在999pi.org上。这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。
I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, every tweets at Troupleman, but right now, the good, the bad, the ugly of sci-fi interfaces are all at 999pi.org. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我给罗曼·马尔斯发推特，萨姆在Sam listens发推特，every在Troupleman发推特，但现在，科幻界面好的、坏的、丑陋的一面都集中在 999pi.org。Radio tapio。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。